for the second day running Hong Kong
leader Carrie Lam had difficulty getting
her point across on the floor of the
Legislative Council drowned out by
heckling from members of the opposition
chanting slogans of the protest movement
now in its fifth month as on Wednesday
lamps question-and-answer session about
her policy address was twice halted
before she could finish probation
council members condemned the protest in
the chamber as a legislative councilor I
don't think that any electrical member
should use any kind of violence
including verbal or physical violence in
the chamber to express their we were
hours before the Legislative Council
session the leader of a human rights
organization behind the largest peaceful
marches over the last four months here
was brutally attacked
Jimmy Shan was assaulted on Wednesday
night by as many as five masked men who
beat him with hammers he's in a stable
condition in hospital the attack in the
Mong Kok area of Hong Kong was the
second in two months against sham the
head of the civil human rights front
jimmy sham is the convener of the civil
human rights front which is a totem in
Hong Kong for peaceful protest and this
attack this very vicious attack that
took place practically on the eve of his
a call for yet another a massive a
protest parade in Hong Kong on Sunday
one of the messages sham has sent from
the hospital he's appealing for Sunday's
March to be safe law-abiding and
peaceful Scott hilar al Jazeera Hong
Kong